في
جناح الأطفال المزدحم هذا في مستشفى عبس الرئيسي
في شمال اليمن ،
تتنافس الأمهات القلقات على الاهتمام بينما يقوم
المنتصر علي العشوة بجولاته ،
تدعى هذه الطفلة الصغيرة حفصة
والدتها تخبر الطبيب حفصة أن لديها
خمسة أشقاء جميعهم يعانون من سوء التغذية
ولكن حفصة هي  شخص واحد فقط يستطيع
تحمل تكلفة الدواء مقابل
السلام
، تخبر هذه الأم لطفل يبلغ من العمر ثمانية أشهر
فيكتوريا أن ابنها الصغير لم يعد قادرًا على
رفع رأسه ،
إنه ضعيف جدًا ، بطنه الصغير
منتفخ بشكل مؤلم ، علامة
منبهة لسوء التغذية الحاد
الصفوف الأجنبية و  صفوف من الأطفال الجوعى
أجسادهم مجردة من الدهون بحيث
يصعب تصديق كل خطوة ولكن
هؤلاء هم المحظوظون هؤلاء هم
الأطفال الذين يستطيع آباؤهم تحمل تكاليف
رحلة السيارة إلى المستشفى
[موسيقى]
حتى بالنسبة لليمن ، هذا ليس هو القاعدة
توفي هذا المريض هذا الأسبوع وهي
طفلة تبلغ من العمر عامًا واحدًا تُدعى فاطمة ، ومن الصعب جدًا تتبع الأرقام الدقيقة لوفيات الأطفال لأن
الكثير من الأطفال لا
يصلون إلى المستشفى.
يعرف الطبيب أن الأمور
تزداد سوءًا
[موسيقى]
لماذا هذا النقص في التمويل
كان يتحدث عن أن ثمانين بالمائة من
سكان اليمن البالغ عددهم ثلاثين مليون نسمة
يعتمدون على
المساعدات التي يعيش غالبيتهم في منطقة
أنصار الحوثي التي تسيطر عليها
شمال الحوثيين.  في محاولة للسيطرة على
تدفق المساعدات ، وضعت الولايات المتحدة قيودًا على وكالات الأمم المتحدة
في المناطق
الخاضعة لسيطرتها في المسيرة ، وعلقت الولايات المتحدة
الكثير من مساعداتها إلى الشمال
بسبب مخاوف من اختلاس الحوثيين.
خفضت الولايات المتحدة والإمارات والسعودية
إنفاق الولايات المتحدة على مساعداتهم اليمنية ، حيث انخفضت من
مليار
إلى 411 مليون سعودي من
أكثر من مليار إلى نصف ذلك مع
22.8 مليون فقط
تلقوا بالفعل ، ولم تقدم الإمارات العربية المتحدة
أي دولار لمناشدة الأمم المتحدة لليمن لعام 2020
cnn  تمكنت من الوصول إلى وثيقة
إحاطة داخلية سرية للأمم
المتحدة أكدت لنا وكالات الأمم المتحدة محتوياتها
في أعقاب  انخفاض المساعدات الخارجية
، أغلقت الأمم المتحدة ما يقرب
من 75 من برامجها
في تحقيقات CNN السابقة ، وتعقبنا
الأرقام التسلسلية
للأسلحة في اليمن إلى صفقات الأسلحة
بين المملكة العربية السعودية والإمارات العربية
المتحدة والولايات المتحدة ، مما يثبت أن
الحكومة الأمريكية قد
استفادت من فوضى الحرب.  في
اليمن
ووكالات الإغاثة تخبرنا أن
سحب المساعدات يهدد بإحداث
المزيد من الفوضى
تدفع ابنها المعاق على كرسي متحرك كبير
يستخدم لتلقي الدعم من خلال
برنامج غير ممول
الآن ، فهي لا تستطيع حتى تحمل تكاليف نقل ابنها
عاصم إلى المستشفى
بسبب سوء التغذية.  تركت أرسين معاقًا عقليًا
وعليها أن تختار بين إطعامه أو
دفع تكاليف العلاج
تحمله عبر الزقاق الصغير
الذي يؤدي إلى موقع البناء نصف المكتمل
حيث
أقامت هي وعائلات نازحة أخرى
ملاجئ مؤقتة حتى قبل بضعة أشهر.
كنا مثل أي طفل صغير ولكن بعد أن
نزحت الأسرة من منزلها بسبب
القتال
الآن يعيشون
هنا تعليق المساعدات ه  دفع الناس
في الشمال الذي يسيطر عليه الحوثيون إلى
عزلة أعمق قد يكون الشمال
بالفعل في حالة مجاعة وقد لا نعرف
حتى
أن لندن
تلقت ردودًا على
تقاريرنا من المملكة العربية السعودية
والولايات المتحدة والإمارات العربية المتحدة
الآن الخارجية السعودية
تقول الوزارة إنها تقدم ما يقرب من 77
مليون لليمن هذا العام
وقالت لشبكة CNN إنها تعتزم الوفاء
بالتزاماتها الكاملة ،
لكن التأخير هو صرف
المساعدات التي تعهدت بها
بناءً على طلب من
الأمم المتحدة
لدفع التعهد المعلن دفعة
واحدة
مقدمًا.  الدفع لكل
وكالة من وكالات الأمم المتحدة الفردية ، منظمة المعونة الأمريكية ،
وجهت أصابع الاتهام بقوة
إلى الهوَّات لعرقلة
توزيع المساعدات في الشمال ،
لكنهم يقولون إنهم يواصلون دعم
عمليات الأمم المتحدة في جميع أنحاء البلاد وبعض
أنشطة شركائنا في المنظمات غير الحكومية المنقذة للحياة
في  في الشمال ويقولون إنهم إلى
حد بعيد أكبر
مانح للاستجابة الإنسانية لليمن هذا
العام
والإمارات العربية المتحدة  وقالت أتيس لشبكة CNN إنها
كانت أول دولة تستجيب
لتفشي فيروس كورونا
في اليمن وهي واحدة من أكبر
الجهات المانحة للمساعدات الإنسانية لليمن
حيث قدمت أكثر من 6 مليارات
دولار من عام 2015
حتى نهاية آب / أغسطس من هذا العام 2020.
وأكد الثلاثة أنهم  مخاوف بشأن
اختلاس الحوثيين
المزعوم للمساعدات